OK.
Let's get started.
How's everyone doing?
Wonderful.
Come on, let's do
better than that.
How is everyone doing?
Wonderful!
Thank you.
Welcome to 3.091.
This is the first day.
And I'm really excited.
I hope you are too.
In this very first
lecture, we're
going to do a little
bit of administration,
tell you a little bit about
the class and how it's set up.
And then we'll give
a little mini--
we'll have time for a mini
lecture in the second part
of the lecture today.
So I thought I'd
start by inducing me.
My name is Jeff Grossman.
I am in Course Three, that's the
Department of Material Science
and Engineering.
My background, I went
to Hopkins, undergrad,
moved my way towards the
west coast, Illinois PhD.
And I did a post-doc
at Berkeley.
And then I came here to
MIT about nine years ago
when I joined the faculty.
My own passion, my own
interest in research
is in materials for energy and
water and chemical processes
and separations.
So I thought I'd just give
you a little example of what
I mean by that.
So I get really excited
about the ability
to take the material
and make it do something
that it can't do
now, but that it
needs to do to solve a problem.
Maybe it needs to be cheaper.
Maybe it needs to
be more efficient.
So one example is
in this material.
This is a barrel of oil.
And what we do today
with this barrel of oil
is we mostly burn it.
A lot of what we do is burn it.
Now if you do that,
and you think about it
in terms of energy, that's
159 liters of this material.
And if you think
about what you're
carrying about as energy,
you get 1.73 megawatt hours
of energy out of that.
But see, I like to think about
materials, again, and ask them
what they can do differently
for me, for these problems.
And so if you think
about that and you say,
well, OK, let's just
take 1% of the carbon
in that barrel of oil
and do something with it.
Let's make thin
film solar cells.
Well, if you do that and
they're not very good,
they're 5% efficient, they
completely die in a year,
you get 10,000 times as
much energy over that year
than burning it.
So it's an example
of what you can
do when you think about
using elements differently.
That's what I get really
excited about in my research.
And that's just one example.
You can take that
same carbon and you
can make a thermoelectric,
that's on top.
Or you can make the
world's thinnest filter.
That's a piece of graphene
with a hole in it.
And that's still working with
just one element, carbon.
All right?
So there are many,
many things you
can do once you understand
what these elements are
and how they combine together.
And that's what
we're going to talk
about in this class
over the fall.
How many elements
are in your phone?
Listen, we just talked
about one element.
Anybody know how many
elements are in your phone?
How many?
Take a guess.
Seven.
27.
OK, it depends.
It depends.
Do you have the Samsung?
If you've got the
Samsung whatever,
it might light on fire.
If you've got the
newer one, it won't.
Do you have an iPhone?
Well you know what?
In the iPhone, there's 63.
63 elements.
So we have these
lectures in Course Three,
they're called the wolf lecture.
And I gave one a
couple of years ago.
If you're interested in
hearing a little bit more
about what I do or what
some other people do who
think about materials
in this way,
you can use Google
wolf lecture and you'll
get to some of the videos.
And I'll mention it when they
come around during the year.
OK, so that's a
little intro to me.
What about the class?
So as I said, the class--
at the heart of the class
is kind of what
I just described.
But in order to do that, we need
to know some very basic things.
We need to know how
atoms are arranged,
the atomic arrangement
right there.
But we also need to know
what atoms are there
in the first place.
So if we know that, if
we know those things,
then we can build,
then we can build.
We can get properties.
We can get structure.
We can get processing.
We can get performance.
And we can talk about
how all of these things
relate to each other.
They're all correlated.
If I change the
processing of something,
I change the properties.
How do you know how
it changes when you've
got to know these things?
And at the core of
it all is really
the thesis of this
class, which is
that the electronic structure--
Paul will be talking
about this-- structure
of the elements holds
the key to understanding.
That really is what
this class is about.
Holds the key.
The electronic structure of
the elements holds the key.
That's what we're
here to talk about.
And the first part of this class
is really the basic foundations
of chemistry.
Some of you may have
seen some of this before.
We're going to build
these elements.
We're going to talk about them.
We're going to learn
about the electrons
and the electronic structure.
But then we're going to
make solids out of them
and we're going to talk
about what those do
and how the chemistry
relates to the solids
and to the properties
of those solids.
Now, I want you to
know, again, this
is the sort of
administrative introduction.
You are not alone.
On this journey, you have
many, many resources.
And we are here to help you,
to help you learn this material
and do the best you can.
So first you have me.
You have your TA.
We'll talk about
them in a second.
You have Laura.
Oh, we're going to talk
about Laura in a second.
You have the textbook
and the internet.
I hear there's stuff
on the internet.
And you have each other.
And I really want
you to work together.
Thank you.
Who said --that was...
I was like, that hit made right
here, right in the first 10
minutes of class.
So the textbook is Averill.
It's a really good textbook.
Please use it.
Please.
It's available here.
Notes, like I said, will
be posted on the same day
of each lecture.
I'll post whatever you
see on this screen.
I will post.
All right, good.
The goody bag.
So the goody bag is another
part of your homework.
And these will be
given out nine weeks.
So sort of like the quizzes.
And in each goody
bag, which I'm going
to talk about in a second,
there are things to do.
This is a hands on compliment
to 309.1 lecturers and all
the other materials.
Now, these goody bags
are really important.
And one of the two
quiz questions,
every week that there's a
quiz, there are two questions.
And one of them will be
directly related to something
that you're supposed
to do in the goody bag.
And in fact, we
will most times ask
you to bring something into
the quiz that is in the bag.
So don't throw it
away and please do it.
Because one of the
two quiz questions
will be very related
to the goody bag.
And the other will be related
to problems, you know, lecture.
Everything's related to lecture.
But at least one will be
related to what's in the bag.
So this, we really
take this seriously.
This is a very important
part of your homework.
And oh, there it is.
Some of which you need
to bring to the quiz.
And we'll tell you what
that is before the quiz.
I want to tell you a thing,
though, because here's
the thing, goody bags are--
it's a little bit of what's
going on here?
This is a lecture class.
Why are we getting goody bags?
And it's because I believe
in the soul of MIT.
I believe in the soul of MIT.
And that is that we learn
best by thinking and doing,
by thinking and doing.
And even though this
is a lecture class,
I still want you to do.
I want you to have
stuff in your hands
so that you can play
with the chemistry
that we're learning about.
Now, this goes back.
I said the soul of MIT.
What do I mean?
This goes back, all the way back
to before MIT was born, 1850s.
You've got a group of
really smart people.
They're getting together
and they're meeting.
And they're saying,
OK, we're going
to start up a new university.
What should we do?
And they wrote out a plan.
They wrote out a plan.
And it's called
the institute plan.
That makes sense, 1860.
It's a great read.
But I want to pull
out one part that's
really important,
that what they wanted
to do with this great new
institution was to do something
that would serve the interests
of the commerce and the arts,
as well as of general
education, call for the most
earnest cooperation
of intelligent culture
with industrial pursuits,
intelligent culture,
industrial pursuits.
That is Mens et Manus.
Mind and Hand.
It's so important to MIT
that we put it on our logo.
We put it on our logo.
That's how important it is.
We don't put some
animal on our logo.
We put what matters,
mens et manus.
We don't put the word truth.
Veritas, veritas, I mean,
I'm not going to name names,
Harvard.
But I mean, isn't that
setting the bar kind of low?
You know, were
they lying before?
I don't know.
I'm not-- look,
honestly I don't know.
I don't know.
But what I know is that what
we know is that, of course,
the goal is truth.
The difference is, we
know how to get it.
Mens et manus is how to get it.
Let me ask you a question.
Why are you here?
Not here in this classroom.
I know you're in the classroom
because you signed up for it.
Why are you at MIT?
Why are you here at MIT?
I can tell you, you
are here because you
are some of the brightest, most
gifted, most talented students
on the planet.
Right?
Thank you, whoever said that.
Agreement.
That was like a like online.
But you are here
because you want
to use those talents to make
the world a better place.
You are here because you know
how to answer any question.
But you are also here
because you are going
to experience a transition.
You are going to experience
a transition here.
You are going to
make the transition
from knowing how to answer
any question to knowing
which question to ask.
And that is the transition
from student to scholar.
That is MIT.
That's mens et manus.
Now, it's not easy.
You don't come here-- nobody
comes to MIT to phone it in.
If universities
were restaurants,
this wouldn't be that fancy one
where you go in and you order,
and then somebody cooks
and brings you your food.
This would be the one where we
all go back into the kitchen
and together we make the
best meal we've ever had.
That's the MIT way.
And it's not about-- you don't
roam the halls here and bask
in this reputation and think
of it as some privilege
to be here, because you
are MIT's reputation.
Freshmen, raise your hand.
Yeah.
Starting-- There's a few of you.
Starting today, you
are MIT's reputation.
Starting today.
It's on you.
So we don't walk around these
great halls and feel privilege.
We feel responsibility.
That's what it means to be here.
OK?
All right.
Good.
Well, now that we've got
that all straightened out,
let's move on.
That's the end of my
administrative stuff.
And with the last
20, 25 minutes,
I want to do a little bit of
an introduction to chemistry.
And I'm not going to
ever test you on history.
But I want to just kind of
get ourselves in the mood
by going back.
So I'll give you a little bit
of history here in a few slides.
So we are interested in
solid state chemistry
because chemistry is
that essential ingredient
to understanding
the natural world.
And the solid state is the link
between that and materials,
and engineering.
That is the link.
And so we'll talk a lot
about this all the time.
Oh oh.
Come on out, Jerome.
But where did chemistry begin?
OK, now hold on.
I've got a pen.
Oh no, I got a--
OK, that's better.
I thought it was a pen.
Where did it begin?
Well, people were mixing
stuff a long time ago.
But really, and there's
some debate about this,
you know, the word
chem itself, you know,
it may have come from
chem, the land of chem,
which means sort of
the rich soil in Egypt.
Or maybe it came
from chemea in Greek,
which meant sort of mixing
and pouring together.
But the point is that
what they were doing was
they were taking stuff and
making other stuff out of it.
That dagger there is
from ancient Egypt.
It's from around 3,000 BC.
And the way they made that was
by taking stuff from a meteor.
It was iron and some nickel
and some other things.
But from a meteor.
And they were able to make a
really, really strong weapon
out of it.
They called those
daggers from heaven.
But the point is
that what chemistry
is about is it's about
how you mix these things
and what are you mixing
in the first place.
What was it that you
took out of the meteor?
And why did it make
that instead of that?
How did I get that dagger?
That's really what
this is about.
And so if we go back to
sort of the first people who
really started
discussing this, we
start with Plato and Aristotle.
And Plato had this idea,
probably some of you
may have heard it, so
what is stuff made of?
What is like the
essence of things?
They really thought about
this and they debated it.
And you know, Plato-- well,
Plato said there's four things.
And some of you may
have heard this.
There's earth.
There's fire.
There's air.
And there's water.
And everything is
made out of that.
Now, you can see that's
a little limiting.
Aristotle came along
and said, wait a second.
Hold on.
If I look out into the stars,
they don't seem to change much.
So there must be something
else that's not quote,
"earthly and corruptible."
And he called that ether.
But anyway, the point is,
it's hard to kind of explain
everything with this.
How are you going to
build a world out of--
We can't even explain
the Boston weather
with just these four words.
So it was limiting.
But then along came these
guys, Democritus and Leucippus,
who was his teacher.
And Democritus said, OK look,
there's something fundamental.
So Democritus, he said, look I
believe there's something more
than these four things.
Democritus.
And he said there are
these things called atoms.
So he was an atomist.
And atom is indivisible.
Indivisible, that's the meaning.
Atomist in Greek, it
meant indivisible, atom.
And they fought about this.
They fought about this a lot.
And Plato, it's said, was
so upset about Democritus
that he wanted all
of his books burned.
That's a-- back in the day,
that was a serious diss.
It would be like if I blocked
somebody on Instagram.
Can I do that?
Is that a thing?
No, Snapchat.
What?
I don't know.
I was right.
See!
That's how-- I'm blocking you.
Burn your books.
Seriously dissing each other.
Democritus.
Now, it really happened
quickly from there.
A mere 2,000 years later
we get to modern chemistry.
Why did it take 2,000 years?
It took 2,000 years because
we were missing something.
So we had a lot of alchemy.
The thing about alchemy,
there are actually
some really interesting
discoveries in alchemy
but they always tied it to
something very non-rigorous,
like oh, this works
because of the phases
of the moon or the tides.
And so it really needed
some rigorous way
to study what things were made
of, what things were made of.
And that came, oh, inevitable
that that might happen.
Here we go.
That came with the
scientific method
in the 1600s and
Sir Francis Bacon.
And I think a lot of you have
seen the scientific method.
But it was pivotal
for chemistry.
It was pivotal.
Because it allowed
people to think
about this question
of what stuff
is made of but using
a rigorous approach.
Making observation,
form a hypothesis,
do an experiment, record.
And that's what
people started doing.
That is what, for
example, Robert Boyle
did, one of the earlier
ones to think about things
and talk about the element.
They were all going
back to thinking
about these same issues,
what are things made of?
An element can't be broken
down into two or more
simpler substances
by chemical means.
So he was at that.
He was going for that core.
What is at the core?
Oh, and then you had Priestly.
Priestly discovered oxygen and
he did it by burning things.
He did it by burning things.
Just mentioning that word
makes me want to put those on.
And so he really
studied combustion.
He studied these reactions
that were happening with oxygen
and carbon containing matter.
It was combustion.
So he burned stuff.
He burned this.
He burned that.
And he said, what
happens when I do that?
That was another way.
Priestly-- sorry, Boyle played
with pressure and volume.
Pressure and volume
relationships
for gases, that was
his way to try to get
at what things are made of.
Priestley wanted
to blow stuff up.
Oh, and he also
worked with beer.
He actually worked with beer.
And he discovered
that the same gas that
comes out of fermenting
beer is the gas that
comes out of combusting.
So you got a guy who's
working on lighting stuff
on fire and beer.
And you can imagine
maybe that wasn't going
to be a good day at some point.
And what happened is,
actually, his experiments did--
this is true, they slowed down
when he fell into a vat of beer
during one of his experiments.
Now, the thing is, though,
that he studied combustion.
And that makes me
think about combustion.
And I feel like oh
oh, I feel like this
is a good time for my goody bag,
which is to illustrate a point.
Oh, thank you, Jerome.
That's going to
some feed somewhere.
OK, now the thing is that
when you go to a restaurant
and they have real candles,
I get really happy about it.
We'll tell candle stories
later in the term as well.
And this is what you're doing.
You are lighting
a candle on fire.
Now, when you do that,
you see, here's the thing.
You're actually-- I don't
want you to think about it
as lighting a candle.
I want you to now from
now on think about it
as lighting C25H52.
And in fact, if you
go to a restaurant
and you want to ask them
if they have real candles,
I don't care if you're
out with friends
or maybe you're on a
date, raise your hand.
Ask the waiter and say,
do you have any C25H52?
And see if they know, see if
they've taken some chemistry.
What you're doing is
you're doing that.
You're combusting that fuel.
See, the whole world runs
by lighting things on fire.
You could light propane on fire.
Or you could light
hydrogen on fire.
That's where we said, yo, hands
on is a good way to learn.
So let's see what that's like.
There's the candle,
which is tilting.
I'm watching it.
Really?
Oh, OK.
Or you could light
hydrogen on fire.
And if you do that,
this is what happens.
So, OK, let's do that again.
These bubbles aren't-- oh,
I should have kept this on.
There we go.
That's really, really fun.
But I'm going to stop.
Oh, I'm not going to
stop because you just
turned it on again.
Now you're coaxing
me to do more.
Well, these are bigger bubbles.
These are bigger boulders.
Let's see if this
gets a nice flame.
Oh, thank you.
There we go.
OK, now that's my
goody bag for today.
We run our world by
doing this, I mean,
not by lighting hydrogen
bubbles on fire,
but when you put your
phone in to charge it,
you are lighting a fire.
Think about that.
You might not feel it.
You are.
No, I'm-- I love that reaction.
I love that reaction.
You are lighting a fire.
It may not be you, but
somebody else's down the street
at a power plant.
This is how we run our
world, we burn things.
And so this study of combustion
was extremely important.
And it's going to be
our first reaction.
So what's happening?
When you light C25H52 on
fire, what's happening
is that you're reacting.
You're doing--
remember, Priestley
discovered H52 plus oxygen.
He discovered oxygen.
And he also, remember,
this comes off of beer too.
He also discovered these
other gases coming out.
Right?
And that's the
chemical reaction.
Is it the chemical reaction?
It's not done yet.
It's not balanced.
Mass is being lost
left and right.
Not OK.
So we must, when we
write down things
that happen in chemistry like a
reaction, we must find balance.
It's also important in life.
But it's very
important in chemistry.
And so if you balance this,
you're going to put a 2.
Because here's the deal and I'll
talk about this more in a sec,
C25H52 plus-- anybody
know how many O2s?
38, whoever said
that, 38 is going
to go to 25CO2 plus 26H2O.
These are the kinds of
things that are perfect,
perfect to keep doing exercises
on though your problems,
through your goody bags,
in your recitation.
These are exactly the--
how did you do that?
If you don't know,
you will soon.
You'll get help, practice.
I know, I know.
I wrote this down.
I'm just testing you.
I made a mistake.
Because the 2 was supposed
to go to the propane one
because I wanted to write
that one and I got excited.
And I went to that instead.
And that would be 13O2.
And that would be
8CO2, and so on, 10H2O.
These are balanced.
And balancing
reactions is important.
Why?
Because it balances the mass
and it tells us something else.
Once we count atoms, you'll see.
We're going to count
atoms on Friday.
But it's telling us that
you can't just lose stuff.
You can't just lose stuff.
You've got to have the--
Oh, and that, by
the way, is what--
Lavoisier, Lavoisier.
Where is Jerome?
Oh, yeah.
No.
Shoot.
Isn't that butane, not propane?
Butane not propane.
It very well might have been.
C4 H10, yes.
I believe that is butane.
Thank you.
Oh, Jerome, come back.
Jerome helps the class
and he helps my French.
Lavoisier?
No.
OK, say it.
Lavoisier.
OK, I tried.
But now he said, look,
you've got to conserve mass.
You can't lose-- you can't
create or destroy matter
when you do chemistry.
When you do this, when you
do this you cannot create
or destroy matter.
Conservation of mass, Lavoisier.
It means that if I-- you
know, you get a little more
than that, see
this is balancing.
But you also can think about
whether you have anything--
I probably should blow that out.
Whether you have anything-- did
you have too much, too little?
Did I mix it just right?
So like if you take-- let's
take another reaction just
as an example.
If I mix iron and oxygen to make
ferric oxide, oh, not balanced.
Two, three, four.
And I tell you, for example,
that I've got 10 grams of iron
reacts with, let's see--
OK, I'm going to give it
to you a different way.
I'm going to say that it gives
you, reacts with O2 to give
18.2 grams of FE203.
This is an example
from the textbook.
Then I know because
of conservation
of mass from Lavoisier that 8.2
grams-- if this reacts fully,
right, if iron reacts
fully, it all goes away.
There's none left.
Then I must have, if I got
18.2 grams of ferric acid,
I must have reacted
8.2 grams of oxygen.
That's conservation of mass.
But there's another thing
you can do with this.
So I must have reacted
8.2 grams of oxygen.
But there's another thing
because if I started, you know,
if I started now with 10 grams
of O2 and 10 grams of iron,
aha, I'm going to have excess.
I know that.
I know that now.
I'm going to have excess.
And the thing is that there's
something that's limiting here.
What's in excess?
The oxygen because I started
with the same amount of iron.
There is more-- but
that means that we've
got another term, which is that
iron is the limiting reagent.
You see that?
Because now I'm limited,
meaning this reaction
goes and goes and goes and
something runs out first.
That is the limiting reagent.
And this was just by thinking
about Lavoisier's conservation
of mass.
I can't create or destroy
atoms in a reaction,
not in this class.
You can take nuclear
somewhere else.
But not here.
Here we don't destroy
or create matter.
Limiting reagent,
balancing reactions,
very, very fundamental
first chemical concepts.
Now, these guys were
playing around with stuff
and really trying to
figure out, again,
they're going back
to Democritus.
What are these indivisible
elements, atoms, what are they?
And all these guys were
starting to mess with that.
Once they had the
scientific method,
they were willing
to go very far.
Here's Lavoisier's
list, 33 elements.
And he tried to organize them.
And in some cases, he
succeeded fairly well.
Look at this.
This is a, OK, where is Jerome?
This is a Tableau
des Substances...
No, not even close.
But look, "Simples..."
Simple, fundamental atoms.
What are those things
that we're mixing together
that we've been mixing together
for thousands of years?
What is that thing I'm
pulling out of this oar
and making stuff out of?
And he was trying to classify
them using these experiments.
And some of these are actually
really good discoveries.
I want you to experience this.
I want you to go
back to this time.
And that is what the
first goody bag is about.
So what I have given
you in this goody bag
is the most accurate measuring
device ever created and branded
309.1.
It's a ruler.
I've given you
five metal strips.
And I want you to pretend that
you don't know what these are.
How do you find out?
You do nothing
with fire, nothing.
But I gave you vinegar.
And you do lots with vinegar.
Pour it on them.
Measure it, weigh it.
Look at it.
Shiny, not shiny.
Different color, densities.
Think about what
the differences are.
And I want to put you
back in that time.
And I want to make a
point here, goody bags
are not just about
the questions I ask.
I hope that you think
even beyond the Goody bag.
So if you use that vinegar and
one of those things reacts,
let's just suppose,
with the vinegar,
think about what that is
and maybe vinegar is a test.
Maybe it's a test
and you can react--
you can pour vinegar and make
reactions with other things.
Maybe you should be thinking
about where that thing is
in the Infinite Corridor and
the whole Infinite Corridor
should smell like vinegar.
But we won't tell
President Reif about that.
But that's what I mean, maybe
not the Infinite-- but explore.
These are meant to be--
I want you to really use
these as an adventure.
You know, think outside the box.
So you've got this most
accurate measuring device.
You've got these
strips of pipette.
And you've got some gloves.
And that is your
first goody bag.
OK, now though the
last thing that I'm
going to tell you about
is why this matters.
And just like the goody bags,
when I started teaching class
three years ago, I
wanted to also protect
a certain fundamental
part of each lecture.
And I call it my why
this matters moment.
Sometimes it goes on
for more than a moment.
But I really, really
want every lecture
to connect what we just
learned to a big picture.
Most of the time,
it's some application
or some global challenge.
Right I want you to
see those connections,
that what you're
learning is directly
relevant to some big thing.
So my why this matters
moment is really related
to these discoveries themselves.
Please give me till 11:55.
I will always let you
go on time, 11:55.
But please don't start
putting stuff away
because it's distracting
to everybody.
So two and a half minutes.
We name the age we live in often
by the element, by the atom,
by the material, by
the material that
was most useful at the time.
The Stone Age, the
Bronze Age, the Iron Age.
I would say we've moved
through the industrial age,
the age of plastics,
the age of silicon.
As a material scientist
and engineer, I love this.
I love that you name the age
you live in by the material that
mattered.
But I also love that we will
never do that again, ever.
And the reason is that we live
in a truly unique age now,
a different age, one in
which we can put atoms,
we can realize Feynman's dream
and put atoms anywhere we want.
The question is not,
can we make it as much
any more as it is,
what should we make?
We live in the age
of atomic design.
And that is really important.
And I mentioned the phone
and the 63 elements.
You know, look, this
is called a revolution.
This is called a revolution.
You went in 50 years
from $1 per transistor,
eight orders of
magnitude cheaper.
In 2012, it became cheaper to
print a transistor on a chip
than a character in a newspaper.
That's a revolution
but that revolution,
it started as a
processing revolution
with one really important
element, silicon.
And now it's a materials
revolution, with 63.
It's a chemistry revolution.
And the reason this matters so
much, what are these things,
is because so many of
the problems that we face
in this world today, so many
of the global challenges,
will rely on new chemistry
and on new materials.
Those are the bottlenecks.
Those are the bottlenecks
in costs, in efficiency,
in processing, in properties.
And those are the
kinds of things
that we're going to be talking
about all throughout the fall.
And that is our
construction set.
And we will build
this on Friday.
So see you guys all on Friday.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]